So I'm really excited to
have Lauren leadership,
a and Alicia Reiner here to talk to us
today about diversity and diversity in
all aspects of media and industry.
And,
um,
this is exciting for me because Lauren
used to be my boss and my old job before
Google. I know we don't talk
about life before Google,
but I did have a job before that and um,
she was my boss and so it's super exciting
to have her here to talk about this
book. Um, which has been something that
has been in discussion for a while.
Um, so with that I'm going to welcome
Lauren leadership. Ayub thank you.
Thank you.
Hi everyone.
Thank you so much for being here and hi
to everyone and other Google authorize,
uh, outside of New York. I do really
appreciate that you're here and uh,
it feels like a particularly important
time to be having this conversation.
Um,
I started working on the book crossing
the finish line well over a year ago and
when I started writing I did have
some sense that with the election,
uh,
we might have a somewhat
contentious election cycle.
You could sort of sense that there
was a stop brewing in the contrary,
but I had no idea that we
would be where we are. Um,
I can't say that it's the happiest place.
Uh,
it's been incredibly painful to watch.
I think it's been incredibly painful
for a lot of Americans to watch in the
middle of this whole cycle as
things were beginning to, uh,
ratchet up in terms of the noise in
the country, um, about the election.
But then also,
uh,
the emergence of the black lives matter
movement over the last few years.
The sort of continuing a intensity around
complex around race and gender and the
sort of breakdown in a way
or the national conversation,
I thought down to try to write a
blog about how we can do better.
And I will say that having a book like
that come out right now is actually
really challenging because it's
not what people want to talk about.
And when you turn on the news, and I'm
sure if you had any channel on last night,
uh, you saw the kind of, um,
intensity and conflict that is just
dominating every minute of the new cycle.
And there's been very little conversation
about the role that we all can play in
doing better.
So I'm going to backup for a second and
just give you a little bit about me and
about why I wrote this book. Um,
because I do think it's important,
especially because I am the,
you know,
white privileged woman that I am standing
up here to talk to a very diverse set
of Google employees and out there in
the world and talking to a very diverse
country about this topic.
And so I do think,
and I felt in writing the book that I
needed to stay a little bit about who I am
and how I got here. Um, so I, up
in Washington DC and Washington DC,
uh, has always been and remains one of
the most diverse cities in the nation.
In the 1980s when I was growing up,
it was over 90% African American. Uh,
and my experience of that childhood was,
I'm realizing now,
and I've come to realize pretty unique
because most Americans don't grow up in
communities that are anywhere near as
diverse as the one that I grew up in now.
My immediate neighborhood, the
block where my house was, um,
we're actually almost entirely white.
And Washington is actually segregated
in these very strange ways.
It's segregated by race, but it's also
even segregated by political party.
We didn't have any Republicans on
our block. I mean, it was like,
it was like all peace corps x Peace Corps
volunteers, right? Like, so, you know,
not the most diverse neighborhood,
but the city itself is so diverse that
all my schools, we're incredibly diverse.
I always had 30 to 40% of my classmates,
you know,
from kindergarten all the
way through high school.
And I write a lot about high school
in the book where at least, you know,
30 to 40% diverse in some way because
the city is also the home of all of the
embassies for the United States.
And so there are families from
every corner of the world. You know,
in kindergarten I probably had
nine different nationalities
represented and that
left a big impact on me.
And I also had a lot of African
American friends as a child.
The thing that I came to learn though,
and I really was, I think like many kids,
you know, not especially conscious of
the things that divided us as a child,
but I was very lucky
because two things happen.
One is that in about the seventh grade,
and I write a lot about in this inbox,
in the seventh grade, I had this
really painful personal experience,
which is that I was the,
and this is like a very seventh grade
thing to put in context because you know,
we're all a little emotional and a little
awkward and sensitive in the seventh
grade.
But in seventh grade,
I went to this very exclusive girls'
school in suburban outside of DC and
suburban Potomac, Maryland, which was, you
know, very conservative in entirely wait,
by the way it stayed in the school. And
the two years, partially because of this,
and in the seventh grade,
someone in my class had a birthday party
and I was the only one in the class not
invited.
And it turns out that the reason that
I wasn't invited because the party was
being held at the Chevy Chase country
club, which in 1988 did not have a single,
uh, minority or Jewish member because
we were Jewish. I was not invited.
My mom, when she explained to me
why, uh, why I hadn't been invited,
used it as a sort of opportunity
to recount to me, you know,
all of the discrimination
that American Jews had faced.
And it turns out that my own
grandfather had changed his name, uh,
in the 1950s from Goldberg to Gilbert,
because in most of America,
he couldn't get a hotel room
with the last name Goldberg.
It's a piece of American history that
most of us don't even think about anymore.
But it was true.
Was it the biggest,
most transformational personal
experience in my life? Of course not.
Does it compare in any way to the kind
of exclusion and challenges that visible
minorities in this country?
Faith, of course not.
But something happened for
me at that point in my life,
which is that I was humiliated and
angry and hurt and I could not stand the
injustice of it. It made me
crazy. So to fast forward,
I was lucky enough to go.
I left,
I got out of that school as soon as I
could and I went to a school in Washington
called Georgetown Day school,
which was actually built to be the
first integrated school in Washington.
It was established in the 1940s at the
time when DC was a highly segregated city.
Uh, which many people don't
know the history of Washington
and how segregated it
really was. But it was, uh, you know,
in many ways a sort of microcosm of the
bias that was happening in the nation.
But GDS was set up as this place
for, uh, for, um, you know,
for diverse communities in Washington to
get educated. And so when I got there,
it also turned out to be a place where
people talked about race and different
all the time. And the school
did something really amazing,
which is that in my freshman year,
when a bunch of African American
senior girls were feeling angry and,
uh,
like second class citizens in the school
because they felt they were not being
treated fairly by some of the white
students, the school, to their credit,
they suspended classes for three days
in my freshman year of high school and
brought in one Williams who had not
long before written the book eyes on the
prize to facilitate a summit on race for
a bunch of high school kids with life
altering.
But the thing about that and the reason
why I tell that story is that part of
what made me,
um,
have made me able to relate
to and understand or at
least try to understand the
pain that these amazing African American
girls who were seniors at the time who
I worshiped and thought were like
the coolest girls in the whole world.
Part of why I cried for them,
it was because I had had some
experience of being an outsider,
that that experience of having been
excluded for something I couldn't control,
right. That I was Jewish helped me
understand something different about them.
So fast forward because I actually
happened to thank, first of all,
I've come to realize how lucky I am that
I had any of those experiences because
it has created. Um, and,
and I am in no way less bias
than anyone else in this country.
I am in no way.
Uh,
I don't understand it in any
greater detail than anybody else,
but it has made me want to try and it
made me commit a big part of my career to
trying to create the
context and the environment.
And the opportunities for us all to do
better. And that's what I committed to.
And writing this book, could we
find a way to do better? Well,
one thing that I think
is fundamental to that,
and you can look at what's
happened, uh, you know, the,
what's happened in North Carolina and
Oklahoma or any of the other places around
the country now where there are now,
you know,
these sort of endless stream of hashtags
that kind of in a couple of letters try
to the pain and the complexity of what's
happening in the country right now.
We need desperately for more Americans.
And I absolutely believe
that we especially need more
white Americans to have a
deeper appreciation for empathy,
for and understanding of the
experiences that a non majority,
although that even that is changing.
So we'll talk about that in a minute.
But the way how all Americans
or experience or in our country,
if we cannot get to a deeper level
of empathy and understanding,
we are doomed to continue to repeat
these same cycles over and over again.
I, um, do a lot of media and I've been
spending a lot of time on Fox News. Uh,
I've become the like sort of
progressive punching bag on Fox News.
They love having me as often as all come
that they so they can scream and yell
at me. Uh, but I was invited to speak, um,
after one of the major
incidents a few months ago.
I can't remember Dallas after Dallas
had been so many this year I lose track.
But after the Dallas shooting, I was
invited on Meghan Kelly's show to do, uh,
be part of this discussion on race.
And I was kind of optimistic about it
because I thought, all right, you know,
they're doing it. It's going
to be nationally televised.
Um, that's promising.
And I get to the green room and it's
actually a very diverse room and I'm kinda
like,
well done Fox News.
I'm impressed with who you pulled into
this room to have this conversation.
And we go in and we sit
down in the chairs and they,
before the cameras come
on and the producer says,
we really need a thoughtful and
meaningful conversation about this.
This is the time where the
country is in crisis. Uh,
we want all of you to bring your best.
Please don't scream.
People will change the channel.
It's not good for ratings,
but it's also not good for
this conversation. So I'm
feeling great. I'm like, yeah,
we're going to have meaningful
conversation. Yay. Fox News.
I'm sure you can guess that
it didn't quite go that way.
So it opened with a one guest
who started with the following.
Black lives matter is
more racist than the KKK.
That was the opener. So you can imagine
where it went from there. Uh, by the way,
that it was an African
American person who said that.
So I'm not really sure what
they found it. But anyway, uh,
and then the next conversation
with somebody else who said,
we should just disband the
entire American police force.
We don't need police anymore.
So, you know, very productive,
rational conversation that was happening.
And then in between it was just people
like literally screaming at the top of
their lives, like as loud as they
possibly Clyde and in between.
And this is the part that I think that
is so heartbreaking to me in between
Megan Kelly who I really do respect and
think is an incredibly smart and gifted
person. Megan Kelly was thrilled
and other commercial breaks.
She encouraged us to keep at it
because it makes for great rating.
So thinks about that. Like is that
really where we want to be as a country?
So in the context of all of this,
part of what I try to do in crossing the
finish line is paint a picture of what
we, not just what's at stake and,
and what did they cause enormous.
And we have a lot at stake economically.
We certainly have a lot at stake socially.
Um,
it is critically important to the future
of our country that we do better in
terms of inclusion and this sort of
overall approach that we take to the fact
that our nation will in less than a
generation, be a minority majority nation.
You know,
we are seeing the sort of anxiety and
the backlash against that really come to
the fore in this election. I think that
is actually probably one of the most uh,
sort of salient pieces of what's happening
today is this sort of discomfort that
many especially white Americans have
with the changing face of our nation.
I don't think you can deny that that
is a significant undercurrent here,
but what it takes to do better,
I think,
and we're going to talk about one
small piece of it today. You know, the,
the media in Hollywood piece of it,
which you know,
might seem like the least important but
actually has a role to play in the book.
I try to make the case that it's
actually a whole bunch of things.
It's not just about how do we,
how much better do we do on
diversity at a company like Google,
where at any American company,
which is mostly where we're
talking about diversity today,
we are mostly talking about it
in the corporate context, right?
How'd he got more women and
people of color to go into stem?
You know how our businesses can do better,
how to have more women and people of
Color on corporate boards and in the suite
that matters. But there's a
whole kind of panoply of factors.
One of them is what's
happening in education,
and I talked about my
own formative experience.
Unfortunately the trends in the
country are not going in the right way.
If you look at the charts of what's
happened to school integration since Brown
vs board of Education, it is a bell
curve and the trend is reversing.
So American public schools
are now becoming less diverse
and it is actually the
private school in many ways.
So for the folks who can afford it,
who get to send their
kids to private schools,
the private schools are working overtime
to try to make sure they're diverse.
But our public school system is
becoming more segregated than ever.
And I talk a lot about that
in the book. So we, we're,
we're maybe preparing the next generation
to potentially reverse some of the
gains that have been made with Gen y and
Gen z and some of the younger Americans.
I don't know.
It's a question we have a three of
challenge around mass incarceration,
which you absolutely cannot separate it
from the larger question of how are we
doing on diversity in this country?
We are locking up an entire
generation of minority Americans.
And if we don't address that and see
that as part of the overall picture of
diversity in the country, we are missing
a very important and significant teeth.
Obviously the business piece is important.
Immigration continues to be, uh,
especially in this election cycle.
A really intense topic of,
of dispute and debate. But of
course, and I know you all know this,
when a company like Google immigrants
to this country, including by the way,
those who are here who are undocumented
contributing enormously to the American
economy,
undocumented,
they were going to pay billions
of dollars in taxes every year,
which is sort of an extraordinary
piece of the picture,
which doesn't get much attention.
And then what I want to invite Alicia to
talk about with me in a minute is this
sort of entertainment and media piece,
which seems kind of Billy and the
context of talking about, you know,
some of the big issues we have around
criminal justice reform and education and
some of the an immigration right.
But part of what I argue in the block
is that what we see and what we see
intensely all the time now because of
the sort of limitless that, you know,
the boundary list,
uh,
sources of information that come
out at what we see in the media,
in Hollywood, on television,
maybe matters more than ever.
And the challenges is that we have not
made the kind of progress in ensuring
that the images and the stories that
we see actually represent our country.
So I'm going to invite up Alicia Reiner,
my dear friend,
who I'll also introduce
to come up and join me.
We'll have a bit of a conversation.
We really want to encourage
you to participate in this. Um,
this is not just about me
and fundamentally for us to
make progress as a country.
It takes a lot of
conversation. Um, so the,
and then the last thing I'll just
say about this is that I do think,
and I write a lot about this in the book,
I do believe that White America has an
outsized responsibility and white male
America in many instances has an
outsized responsibility in solving these
issues.
And in finding a way to understand,
the one point I managed to make on Meghan
Kelly's crazy show that day is that in
the end,
it doesn't matter whether or not I can
understand in a personal or a deep way
the experience of what it's like
to drive, uh, around the country.
As an African American, I will never
understand that I'm, I'm awake person.
I can never fully appreciate
what that feels like,
but I have a responsibility and I
believe we all do that. If any American,
if any American feels that they do not
have full access to the American dream or
that they are in any way less than a full,
let have less than the full rights and
privileges and equality of all other
Americans, then we all have a
responsibility to try to make it better.
Whether we agree with it
or relate to it or not.
And so all the conversations we're having
today about, I believe it's racist,
they don't believe it's racist.
I think the cops are racist.
They don't think the cops or it
doesn't matter. None of it matters.
Because if any Americans feel,
if any Americans feel that our
country is not a full meritocracy,
is not fully accessible,
but the American dream is not
accessible to all Americans,
then we all have work to do. So with
that, I want to invite up to Reiner.
I'm the amazing and talented. I know many
of you know her. Um, I'm very lucky that,
uh, Alicia and I had been very
dear friends for a long time.
We're actually neighbors. We both live
in Harlem and was there for a long time.
Our little girls are the same age.
Uh,
and Alicia doesn't need
a ton of introduction.
I'm sure you have seen her on the
amazing show. Orange is the new black,
which is one of that sort
of few shows out there.
It's certainly one of the only shows
it's an all female cast or a majority
female casts.
Um,
one of the few shows that also has
really focused on the mass incarceration
issue as part of that, one of
the themes of the show, um,
Aleisha along with many of
the cast members and the
writers have also put a lot
of time into calling attention to criminal
justice reform and not incarceration
of women, which is important.
And her new movie acquity, uh,
which she was here at Google
when like a month ago. Yeah,
a month ago to talk about on is the
first all female driven movie Wall Street
film. Um, that was written by,
directed by and starred in by,
that's not really offended.
Um, all women. Uh,
and I've been talking with her about
that movie for a very long time.
So please join me in
welcoming Elise Reiner.
Yeah.
Hi. How are you? I'm good.
He thinks he's thought,
is he on? She's not on.
Uh, are we on the screen?
Can they see us in California, California?
He's been, are you there? Okay.
Um,
so,
so I started to say that in many ways
it's hard to think of Hollywood or movies
or TV, which is kind of, you
know, fun and fluffy, right?
That's the invite and fluffy. It's
hard to think about that as having, um,
an important role to play in the
context of all the rest of the, um,
but I know that I often talk about it as,
and I say that I told the story
in the book that when I was a kid,
one of the most influential women that I
saw on television with wonder woman and
wonder woman with at her,
uh,
height of power in my early childhood,
Linda Carter lived in Washington.
And that was also a big thing.
And she would live like in my neighborhood
and my youth like ride my bike path
or house, always trying to get a glimpse
of her, cause I'm so obsessed with her.
I never saw her. But you know, wonder
woman kicked off, right. I mean,
she was an absolute feminist icon
and for, you know, for me it was,
it made a big difference,
but you know, it,
it does feel like in some way then I
think the numbers bear this out and I know
you know them really well. You
know, the sort of early eighties,
late seventies, early eighties in
many ways was kind of a high point.
Like we haven't really seen a substantial
increase in like women role model,
uh, in the movies and on TV
since then. And that's, you know,
I am here later today for
the Dean Davis Symposium,
which we'll talk about,
not only be actual statistics,
but perhaps a piece of technology that
Google is involved with to look at these
statistics and,
you know,
I just want to roll it back for a second
and say thank you for everything that
you said.
Also as a very privileged white woman,
like I grew up thinking
I was outrageously lucky,
um, and I was teased mercilessly.
We now call it bullying,
but I was the fat kid
and he's mercilessly,
and there was this interesting
dichotomy of like, oh,
I feel like the outsider,
I feel like crap.
But I went to a very privileged white,
the fairly diverse school,
but um,
was made aware because it was a very,
it was ethical culture,
which makes you very aware
of your privilege and aware
of the world around you.
And we learned ethics
in first grade and um,
and I felt very like,
how dare I feel anything but lucky.
That's pretty much how I grew up.
Um,
and never really like an felt a similar
responsibility to make change for
others,
not for myself.
So I think coming to a place where I was
really looking at the statistics about
women in the media was took me a long
time because I had this how dare I
mentality.
And then I did become aware of the
statistics and a lot of it had to do with
becoming a mother for me.
Because what you said about if,
if you see it, you can be it.
I became the mother of a girl,
have a daughter,
and I wanted her to see certain things.
And I then did some research and Stacy
Smith does some amazing research.
The Gina Davis Institute doesn't some
amazing research. And what I found out,
it's 77% of the people
you see in all of media,
which includes film, television,
cartoons, everything.
77% are male.
So when you're looking
at that as a human being,
as a female human being, you feel
like a massive minority. You know,
as I explained it to my
work because it's not.
And as a male you feel like
you're in the world. Um,
and that is something that we're
seeing every day. By the way,
one of the most interesting things that
I heard someone say to me about the
movie Yackety, which I encourage you
to all go see first time I bought,
then go buy it. Go see acronym.
I'm sorry, I get to do that.
Movie's been out for a little while.
Mine just came out this week that you in
my book just came out this disease. So,
um, but one of the most interesting things
that I heard somebody say after seeing
equity with a friend of mine
went with her husband. And, um,
and if you've not seen
the movie, you know, the,
the female characters
really drives a movie.
And it is the story of women
as a very important story.
We've been on Wall Street,
it's also with thriller. Um,
it's not overtly like about
women in a traditional way,
but it is driven by women. And
one of the things that, um,
my friend's husband said to her was the
male characters are so one dimensional
and Finley's on. And she was
like, yeah, welcome to our world.
Because if you look at movies like
Wall Street or any of these things,
I mean I think, you know, when I,
when I watched it the first time I started
laughing because of course the first
time you see a woman in the wolf of Wall
Street is Martha Robbie naked in the
bubble bath. And you're like, seriously
guys? Like really? That's like,
and then the next one is like the
never laying insecure secretary,
like not, so anyway, you get the
point. Um, but the, the point is,
is that one of the things that I thought
was so interesting is this week with
the Edney is and of course after the
Oscars, so white controversy last year,
which is by the way, not over.
So stay tuned for February.
We'll see if we see any significant
improvement. Unlikely. Um,
but one thing that's super interesting
is that the ambiance this year, you know,
we're so focused, there was so much
attention on diversity, you know,
shows like transparent and others
that got a lot of attention.
So you might conclude the TV's
doing pretty well right there,
Shonda land and all these
things, right. And it's,
it's disturbing when there's fault,
there's elevated and lay that,
yeah, that makes us feel like, oh,
we're doing great. Um, because
statistically speaking or not,
and statistically speaking,
80% of directors are women,
similar to 8% of female CEOs.
And we do have,
you know,
it's I think one or 2% cinematographers.
Um,
we do have that 77% gap,
even in like the extras you see in the
background didn't like bazonkers crowd
scene. So how do we change that? Um,
and, and that equity was
a big piece of that. So,
and I think part of it
is true. I mean, so,
so you talked about your daughter and I
haven't talked about my kid, but it is,
um, sort of important piece of the
puzzle, which I didn't mention,
which is that both my daughters
are African American. And
so when I think about,
um, what I want for them, uh, you know,
I'm obviously as this at her age, you
know, I'm glad we have doc McStuffins,
which by the way, just got canceled. Uh,
if you didn't know tragic
loss and Disneyland, doc
McStuffins has been canceled,
your daughter's devastated.
She's seen every episode at
least a hundred times. Uh,
but you know, that, that question of
like, what an impact it really makes.
And I talk a little bit in the book about
the impact of the Cosby show, right?
And how sort of groundbreaking
that was for so many Americans.
And I think now in some ways,
master of none is kind of breaking that
territory for Asian Americans that we've
seen so few Asian Americans ever. And
in his speech at the Emmy's, right?
Fresh off the boat, I fresh off the boat.
I mean this is like the biggest deal.
I mean,
and if these are huge segments as American
society and yet they'd be like barely
see them. So, so at least you're like,
what? What's the problem? Like why is,
you know, given that there
was a good economic case,
certainly in Hollywood, right,
the movies and the shows that you actually
reflect the country do really well.
I mean, you look at like how
frozen became the, you know,
the highest grossing animated
film of All time. So what is,
why is it so hard to make
change and to see, uh,
disease stories in Hollywood
that look like America?
In my experience, it's a
couple of different things.
One is our unconscious bias.
I think there are so many parts of
us that were simply not aware of.
And I,
it's,
you were talking earlier about these
sort of over responsibility of the white
now and I really believe that to
be true because they're in power,
they are a, they're in power and be, I,
I feel like there are so many
systems in place that our habit,
we all have our habits, you know, and it,
some of them are good
and some of them are bad.
Hiring our friends is a big habit.
A lot of people have hiring
people that look like you,
that feel like you,
that you're comfortable with is just
a truth that most of the world does.
I mean, I always make the joke that
like, Karen's my key demographic, right?
Like Nice Jewish girls, you know,
similar backgrounds and hey, you know,
I totally was biased in my
hiring of Karen. Like, well,
we all do it. We all do it. I, you
know, I was at a screening of equity.
I did a Q and a and this girl who looked
just like one of the girls I grew up
with,
like look like an upper west side girl
came up to me and started talking to me
and her daughter goes to banks for
and my daughter grocery extreme.
And like all of a sudden we're friends
and I don't know if that would've
happened if it was a man,
like probably not first of all,
because I had married and,
and I only,
I only say that because if I was a man
and a woman came up to me like that's not
cool. So I'm not going to hire that
woman because, or I'm not going to make,
be friends with that willing cause.
What is my wife gonna Think?
And these are the like thing,
these unconscious biases,
these stereotypes that we aren't aware
of sometimes that we have to make
ourselves aware of.
I mean I'm kind of controversial on this
though because I will say that I don't,
I don't actually subscribe to it always
being unconscious. And I actually,
it makes me a little crazy cause I often
feel like the constant conversation
about unconscious bias sometimes
lets people off the hook. Like,
well I just wasn't conscious. Like
no, no. Like it doesn't work that way.
Like you don't get to be unconscious.
Like there are things that,
and by the way I think and I think
sometimes it is absolutely blatantly
conscious,
you know,
some of the biases that we are seeing
in this election cycle, you know,
you can't tell me that people
aren't conscious of the
fact that we don't ask men
to smile when they're
running for president.
And yet we asked women just my Al Right.
So I get really part of about this.
One thing I just wanted to share
is that part of why I am the,
and this is not to be like
a pain the off about it,
but I do think like it's
not an excuse anymore.
Like unconscious bias doesn't get to be
an excuse forever. Oh, I wasn't conscious.
And so I just, you know,
oops, my bad. Like we had to
get beyond that as a country.
We have, we have to do better than
that. And one of the things that I,
one of the reasons why I called
the book crossing the finish line,
then they didn't want to just like briefly
tell the story at he knows the story,
but I'll tell it briefly is that, um,
I have these two fabulous colleagues,
these lovely guys who
worked with me in Boston,
and there are these sort of
central casting, you know,
wait Bostonian Catholic guys,
and you would not look at them and
think that they were, you know,
I made a lot of assumptions about them
as we always do about everyone that we
meet. Well, it turns
out that my colleagues,
Brian and Sean are part of this
incredible prison ministry in Boston.
And Day along with a bunch of the other,
mostly white male executives from a
bunch of Boston companies are part of a
parish that goes into largely minority
because that is who the prison population
is, uh, you know,
maximum security prisons around the
Boston area and do these amazing sort of
collaborative ministries.
And the thing that Brian said to me about
it is why I titled The book the Way I
did and he blew me away when he said this.
He said after visiting these prisons and
he was terrified to do it. He thought,
what am I going to have
to say to these people,
what I have in common with them after the
first visit he walked out and said the
line between us and so very thin.
If I had made one different decision
in my life, I might be where they are.
But they had made one different decision
or had one different opportunity in
their lives,
they might be where I am.
And I was so blown away that he thought
of that as a thin line that he actually
saw there being so little
difference between them.
And I thought that's what we need.
Like that's what we need in the country
is we need more people to see these
lines as thin. And so,
you know, one thing that,
and then I want to open it up cause I do,
I think we should have a conversation,
but you know,
Hollywood does have this amazing abilities
through storytelling to help people
relate to other human beings they
might not otherwise relate to you.
So like what have been the,
what are you seeing that you,
what are your signs of hope?
Like what do you see changing people
or what do you think is the sort of
possibility for that? Are we
moving, I mean the pace is glacial,
but are you optimistic,
pessimistic? I'm very optimistic.
I think I am a by nature an optimist.
And when you were talking about how
we like unconscious bias and that,
that sort of lets people off the hook,
I believe that we're good.
You know, there's, I, I was,
um, at an event yesterday and
they were talking about, um,
Einstein had this like core question like,
do you believe the world is good or not?
Do you believe that we're all trying
to make it better than that? And,
and that really is a core question
because if you do believe in the good,
like then you act from the good.
And I really believe in good.
Um,
so I believe that we can only
teach with love and compassion,
you know, and, and empathy and compassion.
And so I, yes, I believe we
are changing for the guys.
I really do.
I think it takes a lot of
conversations like this and a lot of
talking about the things that are really
painful and uncomfortable and making
art about it and it that's,
you know,
I became an artist because I felt like
that was the place where I could reach
the most people with true that there are
sometimes afraid to talk about in other
areas. Have you seen people
changed through shows? Like
orange is the new black,
like I know you've had lots of people
come up to you and say things to you about
it. So what was what anyone stand out
like what do you think has been the change
that a show like orange? I think
it's simply, it's that finish line.
It's people relating to those women
and feeling like I that could be,
well, that's what the show does. So well,
right? It was those stories of like,
you know, that Piper's story
too. And, and it, it's true.
And how do we, how do we tell stories
that create more compassionate?
How do we,
you know,
the first movie that I made as a producer
was a short about grief and loss.
I lost my dad really suddenly to cancer.
He was 55 and everyone,
I felt like a pariah.
Everyone was afraid to talk to me because
they were so afraid to talk about that
and they didn't know how to talk about.
So they just wouldn't.
And so I made this movie and I worked
with 10 grief counselors and social
workers and we created like basically
some art therapy with all these sort of a
different phases of grieving.
And we created a discussion guide and
a journal that went with it as a way to
help people process.
And I do believe deeply in this healing
power of art or I wouldn't be here.
Um,
I think it's hard in moments like this,
like in what's going on in the world
because you almost can't make the art fast
enough to really make impact.
So then I think for me
in a moment like this,
especially as a white privileged woman,
how do I make impact?
What, what? That's the biggest
question I sort of turn over to you in,
in these moment.
Well,
one of the things and then I want
to like open it up to conversation.
So one of the things that I,
and I mentioned my kid,
one of the things that I
learned, I learned, you know,
having worked on diversity for years and
those things I learned in researching
the book is how often minority Americans
talk to their children about race and
how rarely white Americans do.
And one of the sort of, so,
and I had a personal experience of this,
which I really had to face,
which is that when my
daughter cells is now seven,
came home from preschool
when she was three, she came
home one day and said, Mama,
I'm Brown.
And wanted to talk about the fact that
she was brown and some of the other kids
in, in cough warrants. And you know,
she wasn't probably as diverse of a
preschool as I would've liked for her,
but it was sort of the one that we
picked and she wanted to talk about it.
And my immediate visceral, so here was my
unconscious. The thing that I, you know,
thinking I'm so progressive about it,
my immediate visceral,
visceral reaction was I wanted to
change the subject. And I thought, well,
why am I trying to change the subject?
Like it's just an objective truth.
Like what am I going to do with no
teller? You're not like, it's ridiculous.
Like I have to be able to
talk about this and you know,
and so I had to like take a deep breath
and kind of face my own discomfort.
But I tell the story because
when I was researching the book,
one of the things that I learned
is that there's been all this,
like a lot of all this psychology,
the psychological research that's been
done about conversations around race with
children. And it turns out, you
know, so much of white America, we,
we want to be colorblind,
right?
We want to just see everyone is the
same and not as a big theme in the
collection. By the way, if you watch
five minutes of conservative news,
if you watch Fox for five minutes,
you will hear guest after guest after
guest challenge the assumption that there
is racism in this country.
Challenge the assumption that any of
these big issues that we're facing are
about race.
I mean that is this and that.
And you got to listen to that because
it's actually a very significant part of
the American perspective. And if we
deny it, we're missing a whole thing.
But here's the thing about it.
So even the most well intentioned among
us who think that by not talking about
race with our kids, we are
raising colorblind children. Well,
turns out that psychologically it has the
opposite effect. That in the opposite,
in the absence of conversation,
in the absence of information,
our children actually draw
a negative conclusion.
So the very thing that so many white
Americans do to try to, you know,
be good citizens,
right?
We don't need to talk about
that cause we're all the same.
It's actually the wrong choice because
it's actually reinforcing our kids assume
that when we're not talking about it,
it's because there's something wrong
or bad that were uncomfortable.
Piggyback on that. I feel many media,
we're not talking about it either.
So where are they going to get wrecked?
And I feel like it's almost,
it's so much better and easier with
kids because there's so much more open.
When you guys have workshops on diversity,
it feels a little forced sometimes.
And I think with kids it's,
you know,
at our school we have,
since first grade she's had racial justice
and advocacy classes in fourth grade.
And my favorite part,
yeah,
my favorite part is they
talk regularly about,
there are four different kinds of
their bored, not kind of the people.
They would hate me saying that there are
four different categories of human in
any situation.
So in any situation where
there was a conflict,
there's the mistake maker, the
target, the bystander. And the ally.
What I love about that breakdown is that
the mistake maker and the bystander,
or almost neck and neck
as a mistake makers,
that if you are a bystander,
that's not okay.
And I love that my daughter
goes to a school, the teachers,
it is not okay to be a bystander
that it is your job to be an ally.
That is your job in life.
And that's that unconscious bias.
Like how do we train ourselves
and how do we train our children?
So I want to open it up in conversation
in the room if there's lots of better
perspective than ours. Right. Um,
I wanted to talk about something you
mentioned earlier when you mentioned the
mes and they're pushing for
diversity. So at the Emmy's, you know,
Jeffrey temporary,
like you won an award for a transparent,
and in his speech he mentioned how
important it was to, you know, uh,
let Trans Women actually be on TV and
control their stories. But you know,
like the obvious irony of that is that
Jeffrey Tambor is himself, you know,
assessed man playing a trans woman.
And so my question is, you know,
how can you make sure people in positions
of power like that actually do sort of
vacate their spot and actually do
maybe room for people who need it.
That's a great, I love that question.
You want to, what do you think?
I think they got it. They
know first of all. Yeah.
I think a big piece of it is,
by the way also a white actresses playing
minority characters where they had no
business with doing [inaudible].
Right. Hello everyone. Um,
there's a long list of both of
which I talked about in the book.
Like they should never have said
yes to this part. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
And um,
so I want to start by saying one of my
favorite parts is that Jeffrey tambor
called himself out on
it and we have to like,
that takes a lot of balls. You're
winning an award and you're like, dude,
this is not okay.
Um,
and I think creating art that
talks about what you like.
I love Jill Solloway so much
cause she told her story.
She didn't look for like the story she,
that she thought would make
the most money or whatever.
She told the story that needed to be
told in her heart and the story that she
was afraid to tell the
story. She was probably most
afraid to Dell because as we,
as she's now put out is like her,
her family's story.
Um,
and I think that's what we all have to do.
She also said, you know,
top of the Patrick Marky,
I don't know how to do that.
I thought about it a lot.
What I know how to do is make
my art and make my own choices.
When I made my movie, I said from the
beginning before we even hired the writer,
I want to play a woman, married to a
woman, married to a woman of color.
Because if I'm making this movie,
I want to create an extra
role for a diverse woman and
extra woman from the LGBT
community and um,
and like basic and a woman.
So I,
I hit those three checks now I,
I did hire an actual, um,
African American woman.
It was tricky. It's tricky
then to go like, oh,
is it okay for me to ask people,
are you gay?
That's actually discrimination.
I'm, when I'm casting that role,
I'm not allowed to ask that question.
Just like I'm not allowed
to ask their eight,
even though there's incredible
reasons and men ages, um, and,
and so many isms in Hollywood.
So there's a lot of
tricky navigating there.
Um,
is it okay,
like here I was an actress and producer
trying to create more roles for women,
women of color,
LGBT women.
Was it wrong for me to play it because
I played a lesbian? Should have,
should I have hired someone
else to play my own role?
I don't know. Um, I've never
thought about it that way.
Yeah, it then that is I think in some
ways like, right. I mean, I don't know.
Other people may disagree. I think there
are some, it's not always bought. I mean,
there are gray areas in these on
these issues. But I do think to me,
there's no gray area,
no grey area whatsoever when we are
hiring white actors to play minority
characters. Like it's just unacceptable.
This happened in the star trek movies.
It happened in the movie Aloha.
Like we continue to do this
is absolutely unacceptable.
And I will say I just did 23 in me so
I know exactly what I am so that I make
sure not to lie about that.
Do you know what I mean?
I did that exactly for that reason
cause everyone's like, are you Italian?
Are you Russian? Are you, what are
you Armenian are you, and I, you know,
my grandparents would tell me one thing,
but I,
and I've played Armenian and I
believe I am in fact Armenian,
but I was also told I was Egyptian and
I'm doing 23 and me to find out if I
really am okay. Let me know. Okay. Yeah.
Um, I, um, I've lived in Oakland,
California for the past several years.
Raised both my kids in Oakland.
We're like the most progressive
humans on the earth. It's, I just,
and so I find that I just get,
so all my friends who are less
progressive,
I have some friends that
live in the central part of
the state of California and
places like Arizona.
And I just like,
I watched them evolve and you said
the pace is glacial and it is glacial.
But like when they finally get it,
it's like how do you,
I mean I'm super optimistic, don't get
me wrong. But I, these people, they just,
when they are so slow to about
makes me crazy and they just,
how do you have patients?
And one of the things for people who are,
are people of color who deal
with this crap on a daily basis,
loved ones being murdered.
And yet they get up there in front of
the press and there's so lovely and
articulate and understanding
and compassionate and I
just don't know how they do
it. Right. So I wanted to say one thing
about one part of why you had said um,
cause there's a lot there and I want to
unpack one thing about it and that is
when you talked about you know,
people you know who are left progressive
and I'm going to say something really
crazy and I say a lot
about this in the blog.
One of my biggest lessons in the last
couple of years has been about my own
biases around people's
political orientation.
And I run now a nonpartisan women's
organization and I established it.
It's a pull a women's
political organization,
which I didn't have time to talk about,
but I established it to be nonpartisan
because I believed so much that we need
more women in the political process,
whatever their political affiliation.
And there's actually a lot of evidence
that when women get into elected office,
women on both sides of the aisle,
Republican and Democrat are actually
more bipartisan, more productive,
more likely to put the issue, be interest
of the country ahead of their own.
So I had to actually go
out and this is my own,
like I've talked a lot about this.
I didn't know any conservative women.
Like I didn't have any
conservative friends.
I thought I had nothing
in common with them.
And so I went through a
process of seeking out, um,
some Republican women who were very well
respected in the political world and my
relationships with them were
life altering, life altering.
And I see you shaking your head.
I know we don't agree on everything.
We won't agree on
everything, but the, the,
the challenge that we
have in the country today.
Now if you ask me do I think I do,
I think that there is,
um,
that I want to sit down with someone
in the alt right or with a white
supremacists,
uh,
or somebody who is a virulent antisemite
and I try to have like a rational
conversation so we can understand each
other better. No, I will say that no,
I have nothing in common with somebody
who is that hateful about entire groups
of people.
I cannot relate to that.
And I wish I was a better person that
I'd be willing to take that on account.
But the truth is the vast majority of
Americans are nowhere near those polar
ends of the scale.
And it is the sort of dystopian world
of the current media cycle that makes us
think that is the case.
And it means that we're less likely to
have some very important conversations.
And there are a lot of common bond between
people who have different political
views. And if we can't have
those conversations, if
we're so uncomfortable with,
I'm like, it's another piece
of the equation, right, that,
that we have to be able to do that and
defined common bounce around and to
respect each other.
And look,
I think that is in some ways happening
in this election. I mean, you know,
the Republicans who had subscribed to
never Trump specifically because of the
racism and the misogyny that has been so,
uh,
such a critical part of this campaign.
You know,
I may not agree with
them on a lot of things,
but I certainly agree with
them on that. So, you know,
my only point is that I think we have
to see those conversations across the
political divide.
It's still a part of the same equation.
If it's hard and it's
uncomfortable and we all hate it,
cause the challenge and make it
look like challenge and we're not,
I don't like watching Fox News and
make me mad because I don't agree.
But I do it and I go on the show and
I do it because I don't know how I
understand the country if I own,
if I'm totally tuning it out,
just as I would want them watching
it. And I said, why, why, why?
I just thought that would want more
conservatives watching MSNBC. Right. So,
I mean,
these are the ones he's like big,
hard thing that like we're
going to have to fake, you know,
or else like in length,
we're okay with where we are today,
which I think most of us probably aren't.
Okay.
It's in no way meant as a criticism.
And I think, you know, we're all,
we're all doing our bath to try to
like to contribute to, you know,
about her death cards. But I, but how
does it to say something about that? Yeah,
please.
Yeah,
I have a more like similar on adding
on that I thought you would give you an
easier question there.
I live in Queens, um,
which is I guess the word is, yeah, it is,
I believe the voice most
diverse, uh, neighborhood.
Now I'm 64. I'm lucky on battery.
However, when I was growing up,
I grew up in India where, uh, I
had my own beatings about that,
that before a nineties,
um,
I would go and do each
other like neighbors homes,
whether they were Hindus and Muslims,
doesn't matter.
I would go into a mosque right
away without much issues.
Suddenly I realize something happened.
Everybody was talking about,
it was like 91 92 and then we stopped
going to each of their houses unless they
were the same religion.
We stopped going to across the mosque
and dumpers something happened and I
realize, oh, some Moscow's to
[inaudible] 91 and the God issue.
And then that segregation, to my surprise
when I went back a couple of years ago,
he's still there.
Yeah.
So now that actually I taught
like somehow in my mind I had ah,
that's the temporary, it will go away when
no, across the generations still there.
So segregation has been, they
just stay. That's what my take is,
unless you do something about it.
So
what does it end?
People ask us all the time and I get off
all the time with someone who works on
this stuff.
I get asked all the time like,
do you think that just
the rise of Gen y right,
that the Gen y in the United States as
the most diverse generation in it and had
three most well educated generation in
history that like that's just going to
like change things, right? Um,
I don't know that it does automatically.
Like I actually think it does take work
and I'm glad you mentioned the religious
piece. They, I wrote a little
bit about that. But you know,
that's another place where like
we make choices every day, right?
About the kinds of searches that we go
to and whether or not we're choosing
churches and then a guide that are,
you know,
are mosques that are welcoming and
inclusive or not. Um, you know,
I think in the Christian community,
especially because, you know, you could,
there are so many different sort of,
there's just a thousand flavors, right?
Uh, that, that question of like,
do you think churches that are
more diverse or lots of earth,
and it's another way that we make
those threats with birth families and,
you know, create conversation
or not. But, um, you know,
these are very closely held beliefs
and people get very uncomfortable when
they're closely, I'll believe, or
in any way challenge. But I mean,
not the parality of our nation. I'm like,
how do we not do that? Like, I dunno.
And you know, the, in the film, like
there's been so much on that. Anyway,
I was just going to, sorry,
did you have anything else?
So on that,
I think with four year olds,
we'd have an easier shot there
because then they had, they have,
they can keep three things in their
mind. Right? And if they decide the hey,
um, if they talked to everybody and
uh, Jack with everybody had been,
that's the best star.
So I have a four year old and he asked
me something that he wants to be a guard.
Like he wants you to be best. He
wants to be that. I thought, Oh yeah,
you can choose the board has come to this,
you can be whatever you want later on,
but not now let's figure out
what you wanted to be. Um,
so if he asks me how is like
meeting different people,
are different kinds of people is useful?
Like how is diversity useful to him?
And you have to say only three things
because it's a four year old, right?
They can't remember more than
three. Hey, what would you say? How,
why would diversity be useful to
you growing up later in life? Okay.
I took her to a four year old.
You're saying here for y'all,
I don't know what to do say,
but
yeah, four year old love
[inaudible] what would your thing,
um, I love that question.
So if my four year old ass,
I just want to make clear with my four
year old asked me why is diversity
important?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Useful
to them growing up,
crossing the Timnath Lane.
My honest answer if she said that right
now, so I'm a mat, I'm an actress,
so I have to like imagine that I'm doing
a new playground.
No, you're too pretty. Uh, no, I uh,
I would say baby
like don't,
don't know. I wouldn't say that because
we need more time to prepare. I do,
but I would,
I would really say the more
experience we have of life,
the more,
the more we know of the more
people and the more experiences,
the more compassion we have,
the more we can serve.
And then I would give a concrete example
because that's all like bad me, man,
my man, my man. So that I,
what I'm thinking about right now
is what's the concrete example?
And I would,
I would probably get a
book about two kids, like,
and I'm sure they had their summer
reading this beautiful book about like,
you walk a mile in my shoes and I walk
a mile in yours and how do we then
appreciate each other's lives?
And it really is what
Lauren was talking about,
about like make friends with that
super conservative guy that you don't
understand. Because if you
understand him in that process,
he'll understand you.
I was actually thinking,
I dare anyone to come make this with me.
I want to make like a little,
it's sort of like a Saturday night
live sketch up like we're friend,
you're conservative white now. Um, like,
because for me that's really
hard sometimes because
their opinions are so not
mine. And I can, I,
can I have my own unconscious bias
about that and how do we create more
situations where we're in rooms together
where we're understanding and then can
have compassion for each other. I'll
say like my, my little wrap up without,
I'm sorry about, um, what I talk about,
and this is a direct quote from Effie
Brown who's an amazing producer and she
talks about three things you can do to
change things for women are higher mentor
and in bath.
So hire more women,
investing in women.
And if you can't do either
of those mentor. Yup.
So we're out of time.
I don't have all the answers and I
definitely didn't write the book because I
had all the answers.
Um,
I tried to ask some questions that I hope
we'll all keep thinking about it and I
would really, I would love for you
to buy the book for free leave. Um,
but I would especially love for you to
continue this conversation, you know,
through social channels and
with your friends and online.
Like we need this conversation
now maybe more than ever before,
certainly in our lifetime and we need
it thoughtfully and inclusively and,
um, we need to bring our best to it. Um,
because this is some of
the most complicated and
difficult challenges of our
time, and I think it takes
all of us working towards it,
working towards a solution
to make it better.
So thank you so much to Karen
and to everyone in Google.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you.